[Music]
okay so I want to tell you about the
question of assimilating hamiltonians by
other hamiltonians and this is the joint
work with low zoom a student of lucan
from Harvard so okay so so basically
this goes back to John hyung ha remark
about the fact that we want but the
ground states or maybe the gap and
that's it now surprisingly we looked for
formal definitions of this and we didn't
actually find any anyplace where this
was rigorously defined like what is the
goal and and what's the formalism
etcetera so we had to define it so I'll
show you the definition of this of what
I mean by one Hamiltonian similarly
stimulating another actually gap
simulating another so H is sort of
simulated by H tilde which works on some
on some Hilbert space tensor have
overused H I don't know C tends or C and
Sylla and and basically what we want to
do is we want that this thing will
characterize the properties of the
ground state of this thing and the
question once once we define it
correctly is what are the resources
required to do that I should say that in
things like retributive grad gadgets and
stuff like that what you actually do is
simulate the whole thing so I don't want
that so if I want to just simulate the
ground state the question is what are
the resources required and one question
which is very reasonable to ask is can I
remove interactions from the interaction
graph I have here some n qubits or some
interaction graph and I want to maybe
specify the graph I want to do something
to this graph make it simpler I want to
remove edges I want to make the degree
small maybe the degree is very large
I want to dilute the diluted I want to
do something like specify the graph I'm
using this very vaguely so I'm going to
define this notion and then I'm going to
prove asked the question of whether we
can always do this and answer and prove
a theorem
I mean tell you about the theorem it
says no in the quantum case and in the
classical case we know that it will be
possible so this will be an example
where such a task is impossible in the
quantum case for a particular
Hamiltonian so what's the definition
first of all okay so we have a
Hamiltonian we have some spectrum and
there's a gap here and we want the new
Hamiltonian to act on another space such
such that the speckle gap is preserved
and such that so there are two different
definitions and I'll leave you to think
for a moment what will be the stronger
one so the first one is that the
projector on this ground space minus P
Tenzer some projector on the insula of
the addition some some subspace of the
ancillary tional qubits this is less
than Epsilon that's one definition and
the other definition is a tilde minus a
tensor one and Sylla times P tilde
that's less than Delta
which is stronger
okay I'll tell you this means this is
much stronger this sort of preserves the
coherence in the Subspace whereas this
just tells you that the projection of
the ground space of the new Hamiltonian
when you look at when you ignore the the
ancilla and you consider just the the
support on the original space it is
contained in the original ground space
so that's much weaker that's sort of
incoherent that's coherent and but when
there is a unique ground state they turn
out to be the same so lemma epsilon is
over Delta or something like that this
is by the way the straightforward thing
gives me a factor of the dimension but
you can get rid of it which is important
and then and then what you want to do is
we want to simulate one a gap simulator
Hamiltonian by a Hamiltonian with much
with many less with much less degree
with a constant degree and theorem is
that there exist a Hamiltonian
Hamiltonian such that there is no gap
simulation like that with a constant
degree as long as the the interaction
strength is constant and no matter how
many terms we add ok so that means that
you cannot you cannot do a degree
reduction in the quantum world whereas
in the classical world you can do the
gray reduction if you don't care about
coherence you can always replace a set
of constraints by a set of constraints
with a constant degree in a way which is
very simple by adding an until I
essentially by adding more okay that's
it I think
[Applause]
yeah thank you so how do I show this so
first of all there are two two
Hamiltonians that that are counter
examples one is classical Hamiltonian
which gives the counter example to the
two the two trying to do it coherently
because it's Specter its it doesn't have
a unique round space and then actually
you have to work a little bit harder for
the stronger result the the way you show
this is that basically if you want to
show to show this with epsilon equals
zero that's much easier because what you
show is that you look at the ground
state so I won't write the Hamiltonians
but the ground states are simple the
ground sites are just the sum actually
the first time I've done it is easy H a
is just it requires that there are no
pairs of once so the ground space is
spanned by all zero strength and just a
single one and then you somehow look at
at the ground at the state which is the
sum over all strings with just a single
one and use the Hamiltonian somehow
needs to know that there are no far away
once and you write down the energy you
do some trick and use because because
you can move from one to another locally
it works but then the epsilon gives a
lot of problem because a little bit of
wrong an error in the state gives you it
could give you a lot of energy so so you
have to use the Hastings coma decay of
correlation so you have to modify a
little bit Hastings comedy care of
correlation and then and then sort of
get to a contradiction not by the energy
but by the correlation
so did you show that but you cannot
really reduce like reduce the number of
so the lower the degree of the
interaction graph but I guess the
motivating is that was to together get
to construct a Hamiltonian which has
smaller norm now I didn't want to
construct the I didn't care about the
norm I really cared so this comes up in
various situations for example people
here are working to come up with
examples of hamiltonians related to the
area law with constant degree I mean
this comes up in various contexts so
it's not necessarily because of reducing
the norm it's really asking can I have
some properties of the ground state
exhibited by a Hamiltonian with some
restrictions so how chopping of high
energy levels like because for
simulation usually the problem is that
it's too large nor it's harder to
simulate we actually did we call this
dilution of the Hamiltonian and there
the problems are much harder we cannot
prove this is an information theoretical
impossibility result there we cannot
prove an information theoretical result
but we can prove a computational under
some computational assumption this is
impossible
even classically in the general case but
we don't know this is an open problem by
the way this is related we also show
some relations to impossibility of
degree reduction for in the context of
quantum PCP but it's not the direct
impossibility in the context of corner
PCD because of the difference between
promise gap and spectral gap that was
for the experts
[Applause]
[Music]
okay my next speaker is okay hi
I'm gonna talk about some joint work
with you mission Henry on some circuit
lower bounds and some error correcting
codes so let's just start off with two
different notions of error and tangle
MIT and let's see how they're similar so
consider a Hamiltonian local and let's
just say it's frustration for you for a
second so on the left and orange well
let's say we have a we're gonna consider
an idea of low energy which is just any
state whose energy relative to this
Hamiltonian is some smaller than some
epsilon fraction and on the right we
have this notion of low error which is
any state which up to some Epsilon and
if the qubits it looks like a ground
state is then you take a ground state
you apply some error and you know you
see what happens and now a good question
to ask is are the complexities of these
two things related and what can we say
about them well first one you can say
that this lower implies low energy
assuming a reasonable kind of constraint
on your Hamiltonian which is that each
particle acts in a bounded number of
terms then lower implies low energy so
any the complexity of the lower air
state will be that of a low energy but
it still sends what is the complexity of
these lower energy states as in even if
the Hamiltonians ground state has high
circuit complexities and it takes a big
circuit to build it does that say
anything about as low energy states or
not okay one could formalize this and
this was formalized in what this nlts
conjectured nolo trivial states
conjecture which says that there should
be a family of Hamiltonians
for which all states under low energy
cannot be generated by constant depth
circuits and this really is saying ok
for low energy states can we classify
its complexity and this is actually a
very natural and interesting problem to
consider particularly because of its
relation to the quantum PCP conjecture
and it's an implication under a very
plausible assumption and P does not
equal kill name ok so there is this
conjecture and one might say what is
there a similar conjecture for a low
error state there is and it was
proved by Elder and Harrow that there
exists a family of local Hamiltonian
sits at any Loera state and they I mean
air lower and the same context that I
did a slide ago that some fraction of
the qubits get affected
these cannot be generated by constant
depth circuits so what we proved in this
paper is we prove it's simple 1d
construction of one of these inlets
Hamiltonians that is not nlts which is
the one on the left and the idea is this
construction is it's a fine wing khatai
of clock Hamiltonian off a cat state
which two presentations ago we saw you
know must have log circuit complexity
and we can show that this Fineman khatai
of clock construction also contains this
property so it tells us something very
particular that these two notions are
actually fundamentally different the
low-energy definition it seems to be the
correct definition for quantum PCPs and
entanglement at room temperature at low
error one is you know it's the right
notion for error correcting codes and
physical processes these sort of things
anything where the air acts per cubic
but cubed and doesn't affect the whole
state at one time and actually as a
simple consequence of this and us
building this NL ets Hamiltonian we saw
that because of this error model is so
specific we were able to create a
different type of error correcting code
which we called a quantum low weight
check code that has really good
properties in a lot of different ways it
is as linear rate and distance and each
of the terms is local at axial man of
constant number things I think we can do
it with seven and furthermore well we
actually can't construct this exactly
but an approximate version and it's also
conjectured if there are other types of
error correcting codes and what one
might take away from this is that a
computational perspective on these air
correction might be helpful in building
either of these two other types
[Applause]
yeah we coats so if you have a million
of LDPC code you can imagine you know
really running error correction over
around I was just working with this kind
of approximate so actually the
construction we have is a little bit
interesting it probabilistically fails
in the error correction so it'll
preserve the state exactly with universe
1 - inverse poly probability but with
inverse probability you'll fail kind of
arbitrarily so I think in that sense you
can undetectably yeah the specter gap of
this code is inverse poly versus a
stabilizer code has yeah yeah this is a
code in the sense that there is a non
commuting Hamiltonian which defines this
ground space which has but other would
small spectral gap that's how we have it
defined
yeah how I interpret this the fact that
so if the cycle gap was it's meant to be
small with would you be happy like how
how should we interpret the fact that
this is this they can get this smaller
thing unusual well exponentially small
gap is actually kind of tricky Elizabeth
a Henry and I were thinking about this
for a while because one if the gap is
extremely small how are you going to
measure it are you gonna measure terms
one after another or which terms you
know it's it's sort of saying you're
violating some tiny term by such a small
fraction or maybe all of them slightly I
frankly don't know it's a good question
I think the gap is important you need to
say something about the gap state laser
cut really de corrected you'd have to
make
all the state legislature acted on like
a constant fraction of the qubits I
think maybe one way of looking at it is
that you know when you're thinking about
the certain codes in a very general
sense I guess grasp a syllable hominins
the the capitis yeah
okay let's thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so next speaker is competing so I'm
going to talk about a result that was
mentioned in in Scott's talk on Tuesday
so it's a result of non-certified
randomness expansion I managed to forget
the title of the paper on your case it
is on the archive is the different title
where is the same authors so this is
with Vika Bakker ski pole Cristiano uma
la Mahadev bhoomesh buzzer Ronnie and
myself um and so I want to tell you
about it because it's based on a very
what I find is a very simple very
elegant idea it's gonna be all the idea
in quantum information that turns out to
be surprisingly powerful so though the
same idea is gonna show up in this brief
presentation also Amala right afterwards
is going to show you how to build the
quantum home or fake encryption using
that same idea then I think Vika might
say something about it later and then
tomorrow morning again you'll see it so
so I try to keep it simple here so let
me first describe the set up so the set
up is going to be like this so you have
this quantum device I mean general it's
an arbitrary machine and then there's a
verifier in my verifier is a classical
polynomial time machine that interacts
with the device and the whole is to get
random bits out of that device and so we
can think of this as you know generating
randomness in scott also reminded us of
this in his talk is is one of the
simplest things that a quantum computer
can do in principle and so can we do it
in a way that's verifiable right so I'm
going to interact classically in trying
to get randomness out of this device and
so though the simple idea is that what
I'm going to try to achieve is the goal
is to force the device to prepare a plus
state and measure in the computational
basis
how do we do this if we can't like look
inside and see what the what the state
is right so there's gonna be one
assumption is this is the computational
assumption I'm not gonna describe it
precisely it's a bit more subtile but
the way you can think of it is just
let's assume that there is a two to one
collision resistant hash function okay
it needs more properties it's a bit more
complicated but it you can just think of
it in this way so I'll take a function f
that goes from n bits let's say 2 n
minus 1 bits so it's it's two to one and
it's collision resistant you know in
some in some sense sense where we can
instantiate exactly what we need based
on learning of errors right so the for
example computational assumption is
learning the assumption let me describe
how we're going to use that assumption
to design a protocol to verify running
this generation from the device so
here's the protocol it's very simple so
we put maybe two device on the left and
the verifier on the right so when I ask
the device to do cause the device does
what it it wants anything I control is
the verifiers in this device should
prepare a uniform superposition over all
inputs and evaluate the function on that
uniform superposition and then it's
supposed to measure the evaluation of
the function this is gonna get some
value why that's n minus 1 bit string
and we pour to that value Y to the
verifier so I put in the review of the
verify of course I know nothing of this
the only thing that I see is that I get
a why I am gonna issue a challenge on to
this device and there's one of two
possible challenges so maybe let me
separate them this is like or you know
there's gonna be two different things
that can happen so if I send a challenge
zero it kind of means well uh give me a
random bit so let me be a little bit
more precise so once the device has
measured the Y because this function is
two to one the pre that register should
be projected on something that looks
like exactly like a plus state all right
except that it's in the basis that's to
pre images of this
so when I assure the challenged zero I'm
asking the device to justify that it has
at least one preimage to this image why
right so what did you do is just measure
this and obtain X 0 or X 1 and then I'm
going to check that this is a valid so
that's the part where basically I mean I
had a convoluted way to tell this device
why don't you prepare a plus state the
way you prepared it is this way and then
measuring the image but that's that's
the plus state and then I'm telling it
please measure the plus state and tell
me the outcome you can observe that up
to that point a classical deterministic
device can solve this problem can you
know follow my protocol up to there
without any difficulty just by doing
things the other way around by first
choosing an X some fixed X computing f
of X reporting that that Y and then
returning to fixed x-ray
so the important part is the test that
you're going to play on here with some
probability this is where you're going
to use some randomness so this is
challenge equals 1 and I want to ask it
well prove to me that the way you got
this Y was by creating this
superposition so prove to me that at
that point you have this and so then I'm
really asking the device to do the one
thing that quantum computers can do
that's different from measuring in the
computational basis which is measuring
the hardware bases right so what the
device to do is apply a fourier
transform over z2 and then measure and
if it does that it's going to get an
equation in the parity of X 0 and X 1 so
it's going to return to me an M such
that M inner product X 0 plus X 1 equals
0 measure how to mark
and so the result is that any device
that succeeds in the protocol with
non-negligible probability where that
test is executed with small constant
probability must be randomness
generating and so the proof of that is a
little bit delicate the natural thing to
attempt is a rewinding kind of attempt
to say well you know if you can succeed
here and you can succeed there then
you're able to find preimage and an
equation in these pre images and so that
should somehow you know you're not
finding directly violating collision
resistance arm but well you build your
way out there so I guess I'll stop here
Thanks oh yeah I forgot so that's one of
the additional assumptions this needs to
be a trap door function and the
verification here involves using the
trap door so we have an lwe based yep
thanks
and questions
[Applause]
[Music]
it was connector
[Applause]
okay our next speaker is Arno LaMotta
I'll be talking about classical
homomorphic encryption or quantum
circuits so in this setting
if you have a quantum computer on the
cloud and you'd like to delegate a
computation to it can you delegate it
while maintaining privacy so you only
have a classical computer and you would
like the quantum computer to run a
computation on your data without
learning anything about the data this
question has been well studied
classically and is called classical
homomorphic encryption in the classical
setting the client would like to
delegate a computation to a server and
the client is a weak machine while the
server is much more powerful to do so
the client sends over encrypted data and
the server should be able to compute on
the encrypted data this was first shown
to be possible by Craig Gentry in 2008
this question has also been well studied
in the quantum world and it was first
introduced by a paper in a paper by an
Broadbent and Stacy Jeffery in 2014
since then there has been one protocol
satisfying the definition of quantum
homomorphic encryption and this resulted
in the first scheme for blind delegation
of quantum computation with only one
round of interaction so all previous
schemes before this required polynomial
a many rounds of interaction for a
quantum machine to blindly delegate a
computation the disadvantage of this
scheme is that quantum evaluation keys
are required so each time the quantum
client wants to delegate a computation
he needs to generate a quantum
evaluation key which helps the server to
run the computation the problem is that
quantum keys are not reusable so the
quantum client needs to run a polynomial
time quantum computation each time he
wishes to delegate a polynomial time
quantum computation the key work around
here would be if we could have a
classical client instead of a quantum
client so here you have a classical
machine who wants to delegate a quantum
computation so he's only sending over
classical encryptions and the quantum
machine should be able to compute a
quantum circuit on top of a classical
encryption in this setting the client is
much weaker than the server because he's
classical versus quantum and the keys
can naturally be reused because their
classical keys I'm showing that this is
possible assuming the quantum hardness
of the learning with errors problem
okay this question intuitively reduces
to the server's ability to extract a bit
s from a classical encryption and store
it in superposition this is because he's
only getting classically encrypted data
but he needs to somehow compute with it
in superposition so he needs to extract
the classically encrypted bit and put it
in superposition and that's what I'm
trying to show here so here he is the
server has a classically encrypted bit
and he's somehow taking out the
classically encrypted bit and putting it
in his superposition and there's these
extra parameters and you can think of
this as randomness so mu zero is a
random bit and R 0 and R 1 or random
strings and they serve a purpose here
because if they were not there then the
server is just storing s in
superposition and this would violate the
security of the classical encryption
schemes so this extra randomness does
have to be present now what I'll show
next is that if this classical
encryption is a trapdoor Clau free
function this is a function that Taman
just mentioned as a two to one collision
resistant function yeah then this
conversion is easy okay so let me first
remind you what chapter law free
functions are so here I'm just splitting
the domain so the first part is a bit
and then you have the rest of the domain
and the first thing is that it's two to
one and the second important property is
that it's hard to find a claw which is a
pair of overlapping pre images so any
pair of overlapping pre images should be
hard to find and the extra property I
require here is that each claw hides a
bit s so now this this function f is a
classical encryption of the bit s
because you're hiding the bit s and a
claw and it's difficult to find a call
now given this classical encryption it's
pretty easy to convert the encryption
into a superposition and the way the
quantum machine does this is he just
like tamam mentioned he can create a
superposition over a claw and since new
0 plus me 1 equals s you immediately get
a superposition like this so the service
succeeded in converting a classical
encryption and storing the bit in
superposition
okay so what I've shown is that if an
encryption scheme if a classical
encryption scheme has a trapdoor clough
restructure then it can be used to
evaluate quantum circuits because it can
be used to take a bit and convert it and
store it in superposition to get a
quantum homomorphic encryption scheme I
need to make this more general so I need
to show that given an encryption under a
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
I can convert it into this TCF structure
and I can do that if the teeth if the
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
satisfies certain properties so
cryptographers might know these
properties so if they satisfy randomness
recovery and circuit privacy then an
encryption under a classical homomorphic
encryption scheme can be converted to
this trapdoor law free function and then
that classical homomorphic encryption
scheme can use to be evaluate quantum
can use to evaluate quantum circuits all
more fiddly so I call classical
homomorphic encryption schemes which
satisfy these properties quantum capable
and those schemes can be used for
pharmacy yes so make sure I never trade
is this like solving your other work
that you'll talk about tomorrow I guess
the one gives verifiability
and the other one gives blindness but
those ones are basically the same kind
of cryptographic assumptions yeah it is
so verifiability requires a bit of a
more complicated function but it reduces
to the same assumption and I guess
they're not quite complementary because
in previous settings they always came
hand-in-hand but I did in this setting I
don't think they come hand-in-hand
because I don't think this implies
verifiability you can do that
so I guess the same question also for
tomate so the overhead for the seller to
do actually this you have to create this
n-cubed state and with for like n 1020
for at least or something that makes a
sycophant I mean I think maybe I mention
time I have better numbers for what
security about them in basically a
number we somehow and and how robust are
you mean doing this with some arrows
somehow so if I cannot I mean if I am
said better at IBM there's no way this
but if I can roughly do these embedding
computing so it's very amazing spectrum
amplification in superposition so you
have all sectors the matrix is fixed
hot-wired and you want so you have some
over X and n is fixed I'm just trying to
understand can I can I verify hundred
cubic noisy computer that IBM would
become somehow that's that's my issue
so even if it's not know easy well you
have a certain amount of insecurity it's
what I think
wouldn't be reasonable to get that say
maybe 20 bit security or something and
so that's already time to to the 2004
Grammy security yeah so you need bigger
somehow is you really want a good
security very issues whether one can you
know one can do this low enough depth
and we haven't explored its attacks
it's the loss in also with it no but but
you know if you don't have people with
what me shots or listen to that yes it's
just goes okay maybe that's
so our next talk is songyang leaves
hi everyone so today I'm going to talk
about quantum algorithms for learning
distributions
which
okay so first what is the motivation of
this topic so I think the most important
part if you want to discuss about
machine learning is data yeah so it's
like basically the data is the core of
machine learning and every every power
of the machine and you just kind of the
clever way of using data so speaking of
the data one thing that is very
interesting is that the data is of
course not random and uraaa many
applications the data are just like
drawn from a certain distribution and
actually in my name a machine learning
task a main question to ask here is just
to that what can we say about
distribution that underlying this on
this data stack basically how we can say
about a distribution using the sample of
it so I think this is a very natural
question that has rests in classical
machine learning theory and in
particular I think people not as a very
important phenomenon that if you take
enough samples that you can basically
have a very good understanding what what
is the underlying distribution is but I
think for many interesting cases it you
don't need to really cost that much
this like basically you can always brute
force like home of tomographic
distribution but basically can we say
learn more about for instance for some
specific properties can be learn this
kind of these properties more
efficiently so by the property here I
mean for instance something very
interesting related to the distribution
such as the entropy of the distribution
or maybe it's or instance the momentum
of the distribution or distances between
the distributions etc so here I think
due to the time limitation I won't talk
too much about like specific examples
maybe I'm less only focused on one
specific case that is the learner balaji
of entropies or maybe let me just
quickly recap what is the definition of
entropies for instance the definition of
shannon entropy is just the summation of
minus P times log P and there is a
natural generalization of the Shannon
entropy coding entropy with a certain
parameter alpha denoted by H alpha P
which just contained the Shannon entropy
as a special case when alpha equals to 1
and when alpha naught equals to 1 as
Lika
alpha powers are a normalized kind of
alpha power son so a math question here
to ask is that for instance uragan
exacts to sample from a certain
distribution using how many number of
samples
k-o-k determined the the Shannon entropy
HP or the offering entropy H alpha P
within a certain reasonable error
epsilon and with high success
probability say at least two-thirds so
this is a very well studied problem in
classical information theory and machine
learning and I think as a quantum
computing person a very natural question
here to ask is is there any quantum
speed-up for estimating Shannon and
rainy entropies so here I won't gave
like the really very complicated
complexity balance here but maybe let me
show a figure here so the figure here
basically the green represents classical
tech balance and also I use the the
right and the blue for the quantum upper
and lower bounds so like a take-home
message here is that basically we guy
tech bounds for the for the case where
for the Shannon entropy case and the
photo for the special case of the zero
and the children entropy estimation and
also this is not like our own work but
with the help of the previous work by
Ben covariant Feiler and also on the
other hand basically we show a good
quantum algorithm that can get approval
guarantees for other alpha that is in
general for entropy estimation and
basically for the Shannon entropy case
we get gather quadratic speed-up for
estimating it and in general for any
entropy estimation we also get a
speed-up but the speed of a system was
slower than quadratic yeah so like a
very brief like roadmap of the
techniques is that we use something
which were from previous quantum
algorithms such that the learning graph
like the quantum counting or maybe also
this kind of a similar than a London
Shibboleth cooling idea and basically we
use are these kind of ideas to to get
good estimation of entropy for different
alpha for different ranges of alpha yeah
so this is like a very brief story about
entropy estimation but I think I
probably all made one important thing
what is the quantum model here so the
quantum model Here I am introducing as a
classical distribution with coherent
query access that is basically real
signals through a unitary opie here so
that basically Maps the quantum state s0
to the state as obvious Oh in other
words as a very specific example here
with a probability distribution of three
elements and with the value of the
distribution to
one six two six and three ethics
respectively then basically one possible
opiates are this one so this is the
model we used for the entropy estimation
project and there are also other
possible models that we can study for
instance you can consider like a
classical distribution store in your
state and basically for this example we
can consider like a state as this which
is a superposition of one two and three
so this is like we consider different
perspectives of during those days and
basically this is like still focus on
classical distributions and we can also
focus on the quantum case for instance
like this kind of block encoding that
has been well discussed in yesterday's
talks and also we can also just assume
that you got a copy of density matrix
and actually I have an ongoing project
with under you in that basically we
study a sample complexity under these
quantum models and study important
properties like the l1 norm l2 norm also
the entropy or the independence between
distributions etc so maybe like a quick
summary and maybe like discuss about
some open questions for future
discussion collaborations is that for
instance is it like in general for the
LCU technique or the block including
technique can be estimate a general
smooth function of a probability
distribution and also regarding to
classical emotion learning literature's
people not only like 4 learning
distribution they focus on parameters
they can also like for learning
properties they can also like learning
parameters and also learning the shape
of the distribution like what is what if
your distribution is Gaussian and is
expectations' variance and whether
distribution has an interesting shape
yes so that's basically as my talk
thanks
so no questions yes yes chef chuckling
is that my algorithm enjoys a property
that basically we define define a
certain random variable its expectation
is close to the entropy that we want and
as variance is somewhat bounded but is
not ideal so it's like we have a certain
cooling scheme that we have a series of
random ribose and this variance is
decreasing and each of this kind of
random learning over eyeballs are
related for for each of the air will a
random variable per se that's averaging
but we have this kind of a cooling idea
that is like a series of different
random variables and with luck like run
host like variances decreasing
decreasing decreasing
[Applause]
Oh
our next stop is separate design this is
making for an extra minute so yes I'm
going to talk about hard moments of
stabilizer States and some of the
applications and the joint worked with
David gross and Michael Walter so first
of all why we care about this is
basically because stabilizers and
creepers are everywhere and from
fault-tolerant quantum codes qkd
nirgrantha benchmarking and so it's
going to be useful knowing the
statistical properties are also useful
for many of this property for many of
these tests and even also in near future
but unfortunately we know very little
about a hard moment of stabilizer state
except for the cases that they match the
higher moments of random ordinary states
for example we know that qubits are
three designs which means that if you
compute a third third order polynomial
of random stabilizer States and n qubits
is going to be the same as arbitrated
States and what I'm going to do in this
talk I'm going to present a view a
geometric way to thinking about the hard
moments of stabilizer States and
basically show you how you can compute
all moments of a state where is our
states and yes so every program as a
motivation I'm just going to give you a
list of applications and I'm going to
tell you how it works
so first first application is basically
as I promised is a simple formula for
average of tends to poverty of
stabilizer is this in terms of some RT
operators which are in the community and
we'll define for you later these
geometric objects that was talking about
a second application is basically
solving a open an open problem in
quantum property testing which we solve
the stabilizer testing this question is
that given and given an arbitrary state
on n qubits can you whether you can
check that status code so stable is the
stabilizer goes far from all stabilizes
and we can show that with six copies of
any any any state you can check that and
the last one is this exponential
definitely serious for those of you who
know the affinity theorems we show that
if you increase the symmetry of
stabilizer state from the permutation
symmetry to a natural symmetry of
worse days then you can get very very
strong definitive serums and but it will
not have time to talk about these things
I'd go to computing the higher momentary
stabilizer it stays and the key to come
this computation is just looking at the
commute terms of similar states and tell
you what the commitment is suppose that
you have n cubed arbitrary unitary not
we for Unitarian look at T tensor power
and the competent of this unitary is all
matrices M that commute with this you
tensor T's for all u and the natural and
a natural candidate for an element of
the common sense just permutation of
these T replicas see tensor powers
because it's if you have T replicas of
your system of n qubits and T copies
unit Aries are acting on eros and these
permutations are acting on column so
this operators are quite answer ends
which permute these things are in the
competent and we know that well if
you're even in fact this this span the
whole commitment and what I'm going to
do is to find the competent for the
Clifford group so we know that the
Clifford group is a subgroup of the
unitary groups at the unitary group so
the commitment of the Quaker group is
going to be larger than the commutative
group commitment of the Clifford group
is going to be larger than the
commitment of unitary group and we know
that the competent of the unitary group
is generated by permutations so the idea
is that to generalize these permutations
to something which is appropriate for
clifford group and this is what i'm
going to do in the next few slides so
first the first step is to just write
the permutation of t qubits in a nice
form
what i'm going to do is suppose that
this our part is the permutation of tqb
so suppose that T is equal to 3 and pi
is just this matrix that come used first
two qubits and I can write it in this
form which is basically a resolution of
identity a sense qubit 1 2 cubed 2 will
be 2 2 cubed 1 and qb3 say the same so
this is just a permutation matrix of
three cubits
and to generalize this I'm going to
define this subspace T PI which I can
start in this way I put this main
permutation matrix in the first block
and I did it in the second block and
what I'm going to look at the row space
of this matrix and this is going to be a
three dimensional subspace of this six
dimensional space and this artprize
permutation matrix can be written in
terms of you choose a vector in this
subspace and if you pick the first three
elements and you put it in a kit and
second three elements and put in a bra
and this is another way to write this
permutation matrix so a look at so still
just permutations what are the
properties of this matrix
first of all any two vector two vectors
are serving ultimate two so X dot X
prime is zero their self orthogonal
property two is the number of one in the
first three is the cata number of ones
in the second string there is stochastic
and I put a mod for condition all three
scores for integers and the last one is
the dimension of this subspace is three
is equal to T so these are just
properties of this matrix and now the
theorem is to generalize this instead of
permutations consider all possible
subspaces that have these three
properties and the theorem shows that if
I look at our T tensor n they will be in
the competent of Clifford group so
instead of permutation I use this kind
of subspaces and I define the RT
operator in this form with the first
three elements first T elements in a kit
last elements in the pro and they form
the competent
[Applause]
you sent six copies suffice for testing
stabilized earnest do you have a lower
how many copies that we needed
everything that's the tight answer uh I
think so
four yes yes the answer is the yes but
it's not written it's not nice yes for
four if you if you used everything at
talks I mean everything is described
here was four cubits but in the paper is
everything for cute it's four D not
equal to 2 for D not equal to two then
you can show that you can do it with
three cubes in some cases you can do
with three copies after is optimal
because cubed Q these are to design so
you can't do it with two what we through
you can
what what is your hope to to use it for
like what's your dream replication of
this so the this is a dream because you
can you can get exponent very so this
guy definitely theorems
so basically use you you make your
permutation symmetry slightly stronger
that I didn't talk about what kind of
symmetry then I use but the stabilized
tensor powers are stabilizers they
satisfy this kind of strongest symmetry
I didn't talk about and then you get
definitive theorems where is the
exponential in number of bits that you
erase so if you say if you have two
billion cubits and you just raise five
of if you trace that five of them then
you get something is exponentially close
to a convex combination of stabilizer
States tends to powers of stabilizers so
that that would be that can be hopefully
useful for key distribution is it easy
to find the subspaces you can't find
them you can count them and they're
usually not that bad for example if u T
equal to 3 then you can see that you're
just permutations which just shows that
qubits are three design but the number
for example T equal to four there are
just something like 25 30 of them and
they're not that bad
okay that's nice
[Applause]
[Music]
Suika Suika okay yeah
so we got Piekarski
hey yeah I want to tell you about
learning with errors and the he drug
Cosette problem and this is work with
vaca shunova still a and when it was
published in the conference called pkc a
few months ago which you guys most you
probably don't attend it's also I guess
the archive
but mostly I want to sort of remind you
of the connection between learning with
errors and Ladas problems in general and
the Hedra Cosette problems so what is LW
e zu - reggae and in ll w is the
following computational problem we
consider a matrix a which is n by M M is
much bigger than n and this matrix is
modulo Q so all elements are between say
0 and Q minus 1 and this is a public
random matrix and now what we do is we
take a random combination random linear
combination of the rows of a we add to
that some small noise so some small sum
vector of elements where all elements
are just small numbers much smaller than
Q the result of that is some other
vector let's call it U and the learning
readers problem is given the matrix a
and the vector u to find the coefficient
s the coefficient s and this is a
computationally hard problem and so I
didn't say what Q is so think about Q as
polynomial in n let's say n to the 10 or
something like that and this is as far
as we know hard also for for quantum
computers and actually what the Reg I've
showed was that if you can actually
solve this problem then you can solve a
large class of what's called lattice
problems in using quantum quantum
algorithms good so what's one way you
can approach solving this problem so
given the matrix a and vector u you can
generate the following superposition so
I can think about some
so I can take a superposition over like
bits B and some vectors X which are just
n-dimensional mod Q so similar to this s
and then I can compute x times a minus B
times u so this is something I can do
given a and you I can generate I can
generate this superposition and omma all
my arithmetic is modulo Q and
furthermore rather than just computing
this value I can actually sort of
truncate this value
so essentially rather than just
computing this value I compute it and
then remove all the least significant
bits like to some level what does this
mean so notice that when I take x times
a this encoding is sort of very robust
so even if I remove some of the least
significant bits then they're still
uniquely determines X and furthermore if
I add a little bit of noise then it's
still I'm still going to be able to sort
of get the same X so if I if I compute
this value and then measure this
register then what actually what I'm
actually going to get is well actually
only two different values of X are going
to survive one that sort of corresponds
to X times a and one that corresponds to
X x times a minus u so if I measure this
if I measure this register that I'm
going to get a superposition of the form
0 X plus 1 X plus s where s is exactly
the secret of this lwe LW instance and
this is going to happen with with very
high probability and if you are familiar
with the dihedral cost problem then you
can see this is very similar to like the
Oracle that we need for that we get as
an input for the for for the heat or
caustic so if I get a lot of these if
I'm able to generate a lot of these
samples and I can I can do I can do this
process as many times as I want and I
run an algorithm for for the hijra
closet then I should be able to recover
s so one little subtlety here is that
these sums are over vectors and not over
integers is in the normal definition of
the Hedra corset but this is not such a
such
for difference here good so you can see
here that if you can if you have a good
algorithm a good enough algorithm for
dihedral corset then you're going to get
an algorithm for for lwe and this
appears in our paper but morally this
should be attributed to reg Evo 3 so in
oh three lwe did not exist yet so what
reg if showed was a connection between
the hydrocele and some other lattice
problem using much more complicated
using more complicated techniques but
essentially this is this is what's going
on and this should remind you of Tomas
talk again you have this two to one type
function this is actually very similar
or even identical function to the one
that we use in the certifiable raddimus
paper and also used in home morphic
encryption and the verifiability
variability works of formula so so we
what we see here is that solving the
hito closet thanks so we the heater
closet will allow you to solve a w/e but
what about the other way around maybe
the heat roll cost is a much harder
problem so what we show in in this work
is that what we can do is not just think
about ba going from 0 1 but take be say
0 1 2 0 1 2 3 and so on
so we consider a generalized version of
the heater Cosette and this is similar
to a generalization that was considered
by charles in front down in 2007 and
what we show is that if you if you
consider this generalization or even
other generalizations to you can extend
this b but you can also add weights here
you can add a weight that depends on B
and you probably can guess that the
correct way to use is Gaussian weight
then you can actually get an instance of
a problem that can be shown to be
equivalent to LW you can actually go in
the other way from this generalizes the
he'd roll cost instance back to lwe
which incurs a lot in parameters in both
directions but the loss in parameters is
is relatively modest so what I'm what I
want to tell you is that if you want to
solve LW using quantum computer which
you should want or at least that try to
figure out if it's possible then maybe
you shouldn't insist on the sort of
original the he'd roll coset problem but
rather think about more relaxed versions
and see what
what can be done there Thanks yeah what
are the indications that these are
easier problems okay oh just because so
this actually you're not losing anything
by trying to solve this problem
because we know that it's not not harder
than then lwe so you yeah so so at least
you're you're not losing anything by
working on this problem rather than
directly ìwe so essentially it should
get it should get like a poly it should
be polynomial in n but still a much
smaller polynomial than Q so if Q is n
to the 10 then you need the Gaussian of
width I don't know n cubed or something
I'm just guessing here in order to get
like yeah so approximate sure it's not
exactly approximate or this vector it's
like it's like different it's short
independent vector but all of those are
actually equivalent on the quantum
reductions with that with this
generalized the sixth extract this
extended version of the he'd roll corset
that with different parameters yeah you
lose parameters in the reduction either
way so if you do the full cycle you've
got to like a worse like an easier or
harder instance of lwe than you started
with if you want but we can't do it from
the actual dihedral closet so in the
sense we relaxed it and then yeah sure
yeah I was hoping for this question I I
really like answering that yeah so yeah
so so I said that if you can solve the
heat real cost then you can solve or w/e
and we know that we have like so the the
Cooper Burke algorithm gives you to the
squared algorithm for the heat or corset
so can you get a cyber control algorithm
for lwe the answer is no and the answer
is not like very apparent so I think
it's more apparent from our paper than
from from like because in records paper
there's a lot of things going on
in particular the reduction actually
blows up the size of the instance but
that's not the reason why it doesn't
work the reason why it doesn't work is
because with very small probability
you're actually not going to get a good
you're actually not going to get the
correct the correct superposition here
you're going to measure this and the
surrounding thing you're going to be so
close to the edge that instead of
getting like both of these components
you're actually only going to get one of
them and the Cooper brick algorithm is
actually very sensitive to the input to
the input distribution so if you give
you to the skirt and sort of samples
from this from the superposition and
even one of them is not like it's not
proper then the algorithm is just not
going to work and this is the reason why
you don't get the sub-exponential you
don't get a sub-expression algorithm I
have like sort of I would not be
surprised to the scored and seems like a
reasonable answer for many for many
reasons but you know who's you know
who's to be a prophet right if you don't
know currently currently nothing is no I
mean currently we don't know how to get
this is not known for general lattices
this is known for a class of letters
called like D lattices yeah but for
general Ali says even that would be like
huge yeah we don't know
[Applause]